from the moment that I saw you yeah it
had to be love gal I can't help but add
or you knew you'd fit me like a glove
what a life we have in store to spend
together and stuff you're a beauty what
a cutie it's undoubtedly love it's
undoubtedly my legs are going weak and
my heart's beating fast I'm knowing I
should speak to her but I'm not sure
what to ask I feel like my technique
might not be up to the task but she's
the love that I do see can hang she's
got a nice arms and when she looks at me
I hope she'll feel the same due to the
hormone that's released inside her brain
doper me oppa me it's a katuk 11 euro
transmitter which means it sends a
message in your brain to tell you that
you think that girl you're looking at is
fitter to make offering with that any
other day and when she looks at me as I
can feel it beating me I can tell from
the shortness of my breath that my body
has reacted to our wandering eyes
meeting and the hyoomans comparable to
meThe
but math theft means a drug of which I'm
clean though I can't say the same of
dopamine dope on me
for me
but dopamine's just one half of the tale
the chemical that gets you in the mood
there's another guy that you'll need to
prevail if you were to see a partner in
the new mode don't mean is useless
without your epinephrine focusing your
efforts on one girl and telling you that
she's the one who's making your head
spin leave this for an oyster then she'd
be the pearl and so I lock eyes with
this girl ready for I love to unfuck I
just want to come up to her but she's
looking at me like she's ready to hell I
guess this lady doesn't feel the same I
thought there was a spark but it didn't
like the flame but I still have the urge
to ask her name but that's not me that's
the hormone in my brain dopa me know for
me
but me and don't forget your epinephrine
norepinephrine dopamine the best friend
you're ever a friend you're a man friend
your epinephrine
from the moment that I saw yeah I knew
it was love couldn't help but add or
thought you'd fit me like a glove but it
turned out that my thoughts were just
impulses not enough to get this beautys
pretty booty it's just chemical love
it's just chemical love you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool fade out